[MUSIC PLAYING]
-(SPEAKING IN ANOTHER LANGUAGE)
-Welcome back to our
afternoon session.
My name is Alyssa Mt.
Pleasant.
This year I'm a fellow at
the Radcliffe Institute
where I'm finishing
my historic study
of Haudenosaunee community in
the post-Revolutionary War era.
I'm a historian by
training and a member
of the faculty and
Native American
and Indigenous Studies at
the University of Buffalo.
It's my honor to introduce our
keynote speaker, Robert Odawi
Porter.
He is a member of the
Heron clan of the Seneca
Nation of Indians, who
served as the 67th president
of the nation.
I first met Rob
a number of years
ago when I was a graduate
student at Cornell University.
And a quick aside to that,
Cornell-- for those of us
in the Ivy League, we know that
Cornell is the only university
that offers a graduate
program in Native American
and Indigenous Studies.
But moving on.
Back to Rob.
[LAUGHING]
Rob, at that time
when I met him,
was directing the Center
for Indigenous Law
Governance and Citizenship
at Syracuse University.
His work at Syracuse,
where he founded a research
based law and policy
institute that
focuses on indigenous nations
and their interactions
with settler
colonial governments,
is just one facet of his wide
ranging career in Indian law
that began when he was a student
here at Harvard Law School.
In addition to serving as
a tenured law professor
and developing research
centers at Syracuse
and the University of
Kansas School of Law,
he has worked in tribal
courts and legal systems
serving as Chief Justice for the
Sac and Fox Nation of Missouri,
advising the Prairie Band
Potawatomi Nation of Kansas
and working as attorney
general of the Seneca
Nation of Indians.
He's the author of numerous
law review articles.
He has testified
before the US Congress
and he has served as an
expert witness in matters
before US and tribal courts.
Currently he is a senior adviser
at Dentons, the world's largest
law firm.
Rob Porter brings incredible
depth and breadth of knowledge
to our conversation today.
This is knowledge developed
through an inspiring legal
career.
It is also grounded in
Haudenosaunee understandings
of nation to nation
relationships.
The Seneca Nation is one of six
nations of the Haudenosaunee
Confederacy who came
together under the guidance
of an individual known
as the peacemaker.
The peacemakers' leadership and
vision united these nations,
providing a framework
for the people
to unite in peace,
power, and righteousness.
Some of you may be aware
of this form of governance,
which is often
described in English
as the great law of peace.
This form of
governance was in place
when colonists first
arrived in North America.
The protocols that
Haudenosaunee people practiced
among themselves and with
foreign tribal nations
also shaped their diplomatic
relationships with colonists.
These protocols later
informed interactions
with the emerging
United States government
in the decades following
the Revolutionary War.
They were critical to the
Treaty of Canandaigua,
which was signed in 1794.
This treaty, which reinforced
the nation to nation
relationship between the United
States and the Six Nations
remains in effect to this
day, and every November 11th,
Haudenosaunee
people grab-- gather
in Canandaigua, New York,
to celebrate and commemorate
this treaty.
It is incredibly significant
to Haudenosaunee people.
It is an agreement that
the people struggled
to negotiate during the
difficult, tumultuous years
of the early American republic.
And it is an agreement
that Haudenosaunee people
have labored to protect
and enforce ever since.
When we think of native
peoples and native politics,
the work we undertake
in the present day
is always linked to much
longer, larger experiences
and traditions.
In the same way that the
ancestors who negotiated treaty
agreements with colonial
governments did so with an eye
to the past, to
contemporary circumstances
and to emerging generations,
so do the people
at today's gathering.
And it's very good to
be here with all of you.
This afternoon
Robert Porter will
speak to some of the ways legal
advocacy and legal education
helps us all move forward.
Rob Porter.
[APPLAUSE]
-Now I thank you very much.
I'm very honored to have
a chance to be here today.
It was 30 years ago
that I came here
for law school, which seems
unbelievably long time ago.
But I want to thank the dean of
Radcliffe Institute and Harvard
Native Program, because it
is always a great opportunity
to get back to Cambridge
and to have an opportunity
to get back into
this world of ideas
and influence and the future.
And to that extent,
I really also want
to just acknowledge the
native students who were here.
When I've had a chance
to speak at a university
campus in the past,
I think you've
done tremendous
things over the years
even though there's further
to go here at Harvard.
But when I was here 30 years
ago, there wasn't much at all
and we were eating those
crappy potlucks over
at the education building,
with all the potato chips
and stuff that we would bring.
And I really-- I'm
really thankful for that
because the few native students
of us who were here at the time
30 years ago really needed
each other and the faculty
members that we had to help
us were very important.
So I want to speak to
the students a little bit
today about some of the
things I have to share.
A little story about when
I was running for office
in 2010 as the candidate for
President of the Seneca Nation.
A couple of our elders
were very, very worried
and concerned about me.
You're licensed by the state
of New York, our most dreaded
adversary.
How can we trust you with
the license of the state
government?
That's a good question.
I mean you-- I had
to have that license
to be the nation's
attorney, but that
didn't seem to be the problem.
And one of them indians said,
"Well, I'll tell you what.
I think I'm going
to support you,
but it's really an experiment
to see what happens."
So I have been thinking about
that a lot over the years
and I think what it meant
was that in many ways,
I still think of myself
as an experiment.
I grew up in the Allegheny
territory of our nation
and I wasn't the only kid
who had a white father,
it just felt that way
in terms of the issues
that I was dealing with.
And my family was very well
anchored in our community.
My grandfather had been on
the council for 40 years,
was one of our-- just historic
leaders on the council.
My mother was our very
first education director
of our nation and she had just
terrible battles with people
in the late '70s, as she was
trying to deal with education.
And I didn't know anything about
this at the time, being a kid.
But this whole idea being
educated in our nation
was an unbelievably two edged
sword, and for many people,
really just a one edged
sword, a bad, bad edge.
Because everything that
the colonists have ever
done that was really
driven in long term agendas
came through education, came
through the boarding schools.
And I think that the panelists
that preceded me really
did a great job at sort of
laying the foundation of really
the historic.
And I can't cover 500 years
of history in this speech,
nor could the earlier panelists.
But I think that history is
very much a part of who I became
and who I am today.
And so it was a struggle.
It was very much a struggle.
And I want to share
that a little bit
with you because there are
certain episodes that happened
in my life that really no
one would ever believe,
that my tribe went through
during the early years
of my work with them.
And then I want
to try to pull out
a little bit of meaning
in relation to the work
that I've been
lucky enough to be
able to do for my nation--
within the Seneca Nation--
and some of the
work that I've done
over the years working in the
outside legal and political
system.
So the very first
journey-- with respect
to my own personal
life-- really came--
I had some great
professors at Syracuse
where I went to school.
I had my family.
But, to be the first Attorney
General of the Seneca Nation
when I was 28 years
old wasn't an accident.
And I had largely forced
myself on my tribal government
saying that, "You know what?
You paid for a good
chunk of my education
and the whole idea was that
we'd come back and work
for the tribe."
Well here I am!
I've been-- I've been at a
law firm for three years.
I don't know everything by
any means, but I want to help.
And boy, it was hard to get a
job working for my own nation.
And it was-- for those of you
who have a close proximity
to tribal government
politics, you
know what I'm talking about.
And it was hard.
And I ended up doing
some things that
were somewhat unconscious about
trying to get my time in front
of the council and trying to
find a way to get appointed.
And eventually the council
approved my contract
to be the attorney general.
I was approved 15
to one, except there
was no money attached to it.
They said, "Well someday
we'll get some money
and then we'll hire him."
And I thought these guys
are so clever, you know.
But I didn't stop.
And I think that's where it
was some combination of being
stubborn and selfish
and just directed,
that I wanted to
help my tribe and I
wasn't going to say no to that.
And it really was a
common denominator.
But I tell you,
working for my nation
when I was that young made
me realize how little I knew
about my own nation
and our legal history
and our political
history, but also
how ill-equipped my American law
school education down the road
here had prepared me for working
in that legal environment.
The most significant
thing that happened
that really changed my life
significantly was in 1992.
Our nation was really
in war against the state
of New York over the taxation
of cigarettes in our territory.
It's about a treaty right of
free commerce and our treaty
that Alyssa mentioned
earlier about the free use
and enjoyment of our
lands, our people take that
very seriously that we are
not to be interfered with
and that we negotiated
our treaty at a time
when we were equals
with the United States.
And, but for us
and our warriors,
there would be no United States.
That's how we remember that
treating and that history.
It's a deal.
You leave us alone.
We give you peace.
And frankly at the time,
people negotiated that
and discussed it in 1992.
Well, here's the way
the legal thinking
goes of the Seneca in conflict.
Our treaty is with
the United States.
It's not what the state
of New York, so we
can go to war with them.
And it was an unbelievably
tensio-- a contentious time,
but that's what I started
to really see and learn
about how power is used
against native people.
Men-- really men with guns--
who are surrounding your nation,
trying to kill your economy.
And I was in the middle
of the negotiations.
I was working with
our officials.
I was dealing with the
governor's offices.
I was dealing with
the state police.
And it was a very
formative experience
and it lasted in the span of
a week, but ultimately we won.
And the state, the
police, the governor,
and their entire apparatus
of attack was withdrawn
and our people
declared and succeeded
in gaining a victory over
the state at that moment.
So ever since that time, I have
been experimenting and trying
to find the way in which
the power of native people
can be galvanized and mobilized
without actually having
to block the New
York state thruway,
without actually
having to engage
in that kind of
disobedience and resistance
because we should
have that power.
We do have that
power and that power
is needed on a day to day
basis to help our nations.
There were other more
unfortunate experiences
that happened during
that first term
when I was the Attorney General.
And we had a civil war.
And we had a civil war that by
the sort of scale of humanity
and this scale of what
goes on in the world
even today was not vast.
But when Senecas kill each
other, that's a civil war.
And we had a terrible
battle emanating out
of a-- out of an
election process.
And it was really about
gambling, casinos,
and the struggle for
that, and the degree
to which our people did not
want that, but-- but some did.
And it was a terrible
time to be there
and to see it,
what was happening.
It eventually culminated
in some degree of peace
and my term had left, had ended.
But it was an awful thing.
And when I started teaching
at the University of Kansas
and my wife and I
were there to start
a new chapter of
our lives, it really
stimulated a lot of thinking.
And my first article
that I had wrote
was about the destructive force
of the American legal system
and the way in which people
are pitted against each other,
people in conflict.
Which really only
makes it worse,
but doesn't solve problems or
heal people or bring people
together.
And I still think
about those things,
although I don't often have
a chance to work on it.
But that really was
a formative moment
and having an opportunity in
my life-- a very rare moment--
to be a law professor at
an American university,
to have the time, to have
the ability to teach,
to have the ability
to think and write.
And that's where I,
too, for the first time,
was exposed to the
x-file, the secret master
plan for native people.
And I'm 20.
What?
32 years old, and no one
had ever really told me
about this secret master plan.
It's actually written about
quite nakedly, you know,
about the plan to
exterminate the Indians.
And it was shocking
in a way that I
hadn't learned that previously.
But why would the
American government--
why would the American
legal system-- really
encourage its own
people, much less
the natives to
learn about things
like the Doctrine of Discovery?
There's much more
to be had to keep
people ignorant of these things
than to explain to them, oh we
only hold title to
this entire country
by virtue of this fiction that
the Christian nation somehow
owned this land because
the savages are not
considered to be real people.
You know, that's an unbelievably
shocking thing when you're
a professor, a student
of law, and you're
trying to understand
the logic and the reason
and the legitimacy of it,
and the entire legal system,
as it relates to native people
is founded upon a fiction.
It's absolutely false.
So for the law students in
particular, native students
in general, and everybody
for sure, don't forget that.
And I can't say that it can
be done and fixed tomorrow,
but it is an important
foundation to remember.
Now, this whole thing
about the experiment.
So I grew up on our territory,
the Allegheny territory,
and then somehow
I got to Harvard,
and then I went to a
Washington law firm,
then I went back home again.
And I was there then
I went back out, back
to the world of
the law professors.
And then I went back again.
And so it's a quest
to find out what's
the best path, what's
the best way to try
to make a difference, to
try to make a difference.
And right now, you
know, I can't say
that I know the answer for
sure, but I'm doing it again.
And when I ran for
office as the president,
it was the most
challenging time.
And I don't really
sometimes know
how I did it other
than I worked hard
and I talked to a lot of people
and I asked them to trust me
and to give me a chance
to lead our nation.
But it was a different
thing because I
didn't like the way a lot
of the tribal government
policies were structured
and I wanted to change it.
And the people I
thought supported that.
But it's a tough system.
And I have a few more thoughts
to share about that at the end.
But it's something
that's about, is
it inside your tribe, that's
the most important place
to be, or outside
the tribe to try
to influence the course
of events going forward?
Because it's a colonial system.
I used to call it Federal Indian
Control Law because it's not
about some neutral thing.
It's about control
and everything
about the Doctrine of Discovery
and the domestic dependent
nationhood and the Acts
of Congress and the Acts
of the Supreme Court
are largely about no,
about what you
can't do if you're
a native people and
a native government.
And so it is about control.
It's about regulating
indigenous peoples.
And I've never thought
of it as neutral.
I've never thought
about it as something
that you should
be simply studying
for its intellectual value.
It's a weapon.
It's a tool that's used by
the colonial legal system
and the colonial society to
control indigenous populations.
So that's what I want to talk
a little bit about is some
of the pros and cons of
these different platforms
of engagement.
And maybe there are more
opportunities and challenges
because I can't
say at this point
that it's a really bright line.
But a little bit
about why should you
engage within your
indigenous community?
And this might be a
message that goes more
towards native
people who are here,
especially those
in the university.
Because I tell you it's pretty
comfortable in relative terms,
to live in this outside world.
People generally respect you.
They're nice to you.
You can go get 16 different
kinds of pizza if you want to.
And going to your
Indian reservation
doesn't have a lot of that.
It's a tough place to be, almost
everywhere in Indian country.
So to leave this kind
of life-- and I was just
telling a friend on the way
over here-- in the hotel
that we're staying
in right now, in 1987
when they were hiring first year
law students, second year law
students at Harvard, it was
filled with American law firms
looking to pay an
awful lot of money
for Harvard Law School talent.
And the market was so
unbelievably strong.
It was unbelievably warping
that my first summer
job was making three
times as much money
as my mother did as
our education director.
And I thought frankly,
to be honest with you,
I really wanted to try that.
You know, because I think it's
important to understand what's
going on in American law firms.
Well no, the money
was good, too.
And so I learned
a lot about that.
And yet, what is it
about tribal life?
What's going on there?
Well from my perspective,
that's where it begins.
When you talk about the
right of self-determination,
when you talk about
your sovereignty,
when you talk about your
existence as a native people,
it begins right there
with the people.
You can't manufacture that
from Washington or Albany
or anywhere else.
If you're talking about the
survival of your people,
the strength of your people,
it has to exist at that level
where the people are.
And maybe that's
obvious, but you'd
be surprised the
degree to which there's
some delusional thinking about
somehow you can fix things
from elsewhere.
Some delusional thinking of
which I've even engaged in.
But much of it is that it has
to be local, so you see it.
When I got involved with
a law reform project,
one of my first things was to
help change our constitution
to create a new Court of
Appeal, to be able to separate
our judicial elections
from our general elections
to try to de-escalate some
of the politics of choosing
judges.
And in that time in
that window no one else
could do that for us.
In terms of trying
to make things
better for the people,
the Seneca people,
in terms of how we were
governing ourselves.
There's no federal
official you can call.
There's no NGO you can call.
You could only do that yourself.
So that's the upside, that's
the attraction is that you
can actually see progress.
And there's so many people
on a day to day basis
who work in Indian country
tribal governments.
Some of the toughest
work that's done
deals with children and
families, families in distress.
And they are people who
make unbelievable sacrifices
and deal with the most
unbelievable tragedies
oftentimes, but they're
making a difference.
They're finding a way to improve
people's lives at the ground
level.
This isn't just a
battle that occurs
against a blac-- a blank slate.
We're inheriting this
unbelievable legacy
of colonization.
And the efforts that were taken
by the American government,
in conspiracy with a lot
of other actors in terms
of this process, to really
destroy indigenous societies.
So you have a lot of
people like my family
who were raised in
boarding schools
for which my grandmother
was beaten as a small child
because she was speaking
the Seneca language.
And that had a real
consequence in terms
of the degree to which
my family maintained
an inherent connection
to our culture.
And those have a broader
psychological effects
in the way people
today are living
and the-- and their health,
their mental health,
their physical health.
Those experiences-- we
call it historic trauma.
And it's something our
health care professionals
and our leaders are
trying to work on
to find a way that you can't
just give someone a pill
or give them a band-aid
if they're in pain.
Sometimes you have to crawl
into their inter-generational
existence to find out
what happened to them.
And I don't know that that's
completely true everywhere else
in the world, but
we're colonized
people and these experiences
of boarding schools
and systematic efforts to
destroy our societies require
some very intimate, on the
ground activity to improve it.
So that's a reality of our
lives that self-determination,
our sovereignty, our
existence as a people
happens at the local level and
you can't do it anywhere else.
A related benefit, or at
least important component
to just tribal
political engagement,
is at the protection
and defense function.
How do you protect
yourself if you're
a tribal nation, a small
tribal nation in the world?
A few years ago
when I was teaching,
I tried to get the law
school administration
to buy in to the idea that
I should teach a travel
course over in Europe, and that
I should go to the Vatican,
and I should go to Monaco, and
I should go to Lichtenstein
to examine and explore how
these small sovereigns of Europe
sustain themselves.
[CROWD LAUGHING]
-That I should go
during the summer.
[CROWD LAUGHING]
-And that I should have-- I
should have three weeks or so
with my family.
At the law school's expense of
course, to take a few students
and understand and
study these issues
with these small sovereigns.
They didn't buy it.
But it's still an
important question
to ask, is how do those
small sovereigns survive
in the world as
their own sovereigns?
And so too with us?
How do we make it?
How do we survive?
Well, we've had some great
battles in my nation,
as many nations do.
But this really
sort of beat down
the path of realizing
that a lot of what
we think about the
way the law works
is really a mistake or at least,
at best, it's misdirected.
There's nothing in the
treaties of the Seneca
Nation or the
Haudenosaunee, there's
nothing in the legal
system of my nation
that says, "We hereby consent to
the plenary power of the United
States."
Now American jurists--
the Supreme Court--
have been writing about
that for generations,
that American law is based upon
this notion of plenary power,
The Doctrine of Discovery.
We don't-- we've never
embraced any of that.
So guess what?
It doesn't exist in our nation.
And I actually wrote
a whole article
about how frankly American
law is mostly advisory
as it relates to the actions
of a tribal government.
If you're a tribal government,
which by treaty have consented
to the application of American
law to your business--
and some tribes have--
well then you're stuck.
But most of have not.
And that's called
jurisprudential sovereignty.
That's the ability to decide
your own legal relationship
with the United States.
And so if you go back to
whether it's the conflict
zone with the state of New
York over interpretation
of our treaty right, our
nation has as much right
to interpret our
treaties as we see fit,
as does the state or
the federal government.
Sometimes they're in tension.
Sometimes they're in conflict.
But you don't resolve
them by running
to the courts of
the United States.
You settle them and resolve them
through negotiation, if at all.
It's a treaty.
It's not meant to be
legally adjudicated
in the courts of one side over
the other as a general matter.
So we won some of these battles.
Not just the thruway thing,
but something as sexy as making
sure that the EPA cannot force
you to get a federal permit
for the construction of your
waste water treatment plant.
Waste water treatment
sovereignty.
Very important.
But that's exactly
what they did.
My wife, when she was the
president of our construction
company, was working
on the development
of this important improvement
in the waste water
treatment of our community.
And the council had borrowed the
money to be able to pay for it
and the EPA showed up and said,
"You're going to get a permit."
And we said, "No we're not.
We don't get permits from you
to do business in our own land.
Where in the treaty
does it say this?"
So we fought with them for
a couple years over this.
Now keep in mind,
no one was looking
to pollute our own
lands and waters.
We had actually exceeded
the standards that's
set by the federal
government, but it
was the issue of the permit.
And it took them
a couple of years,
but eventually we
got a letter back
that says, "We
decided to recognize
your permit that the
council issued for you
and we would like
to sit down and have
a discussion over maybe just
a few refinements of that."
Great!
Let's have a discussion.
That was a big win.
That with respect to
business activities
and governmental activities
in our own territory, that we
would not have to be subject
to the environmental regulation
of the United States.
That was our business
and if the United States
has an issue or a problem,
we'd be glad to talk about it.
That's what
sovereign nations do.
So that's a perspective.
And I see it from time to time.
Unfortunately not often enough.
And increasingly the lawyers
have grabbed hold of the issue
and are reading from their
provision of the US Code
and are paving over their
client's own freedom
to make a different decision.
I wrote a whole
article about that too,
not that anyone's ever read it.
But it's just something that
actually is rooted in the idea
that when you're an
American trained lawyer,
you're largely not
taught that there's
an entire other
legal system that you
have to be respectful of and
that you have to deal with.
And frankly if you're taking
your ethical obligation
seriously, you have to give
life to that legal foundation,
the tribal legal foundation,
as much as you do
the American legal foundation.
So a little bit of the
downside of the tribal life,
the tribal political life,
the tribal engagement life.
And I saw this--
for those of you
who are ever working in
tribal government and decide,
you know I think I
want to run for chair
or I want to run for president.
Your world goes from seeing
things in black and white
to seeing things in unbelievable
technicolor and vibrancy.
It's much more
complicated, much harder
than you could ever imagine.
And I have so much respect
for the tribal leaders
in place today and in the
past and those yet to come,
because it's really hard
to govern a tribal nation.
There's so many
different interests.
different problems.
And I think that the intensity
of the politics-- for those
of you who've ever been on
a city council-- or maybe
the standard is if your
constituents actually
know where you live,
then you know how hard
it is to be a political leader.
I mean these guys in Washington,
these women that travel in
and they do their business
and they leave, that's great.
It's when they go
back home where
people know where they live that
it gets tough, because then you
gotta deal with folks on your
doorstep and at the supermarket
and tribal communities
are very same way.
And they are-- generally is-- my
experience-- native people are
not shy about telling you
what's wrong with what
you're doing in terms of
your responsibilities.
And I think taking that dynamic
and then adding in the fact
that the reality in most cases
and certainly the perception
is that political rewards,
political economic engagement
is a zero sum game that I
can only win if you lose.
And that might be
true generally,
not just in native communities,
but there's an awful lot
of really intense conflict.
Jobs, contracts,
economic activity
that is being sought by some.
It's at the expense
of somebody else.
And the reality is that in many
places in any country, that's
really still true where
most of the dollars
come from federal
appropriations.
There are no new
jobs being created.
There are no new dollars
flowing into the community.
And I didn't realize it when
I had tried to bring in,
well not just
myself historically,
but other people
from our community,
the children and
grandchildren who
had gotten their
college degrees,
try to bring them
into our government.
It was perceived by
many-- to some extent it
was true-- it was a zero
sum game because jo--
those jobs didn't go to people
who may not have been qualified
for those jobs.
And it was very contentious,
it was a very hard business
to have to make those decisions.
So with that exciting
news, let's move on
to engaging with the
colonial political system.
Because as much as there are
strengths and weaknesses, when
your system, the
political system
is intertwined with the
United States, in some cases
it's very, very direct.
There are many Indian nations
and tribes in the United States
that have constitutions
that require
that the Secretary of the
Interior approve their laws,
approve the amendments
to their constitutions.
This is not a federal legal
requirement by any means,
but it is a symptom,
a consequence
of those early Indian
Reorganization Act governments
where the bureaucrats
embedded these provisions
in the tribal
constitutional drafts
that were being proposed,
where they embedded themselves
in the power structure.
And so you're dealing literally
with this intertwining
of politics and law
between the tribal
and the federal government over
control over what's going on.
I worked with a tribe on trying
to change their constitution
to remove these
provisions because there
is no federal
requirement for them.
And a tribe, if it wants
to get rid of the Secretary
of the Interior from
its ordinance approval
and from it's constitutional
approval process,
it can do that.
Well, the bureaucrats
don't often like that,
and it took seven years
of advocacy and patience
and fighting with the
Bureau of Indian Affairs
to get their constitution,
to get their election
approved so they could
remove those provisions
from the tribe.
So the government sometimes
just doesn't want to let go,
and that's part
of the challenge.
That when you engage
with that system,
you've got to find a way
to make a difference.
So I think that's really one
of the first and most important
reasons to get
involved in what's
going on in the
federal government,
is that it gives you an
opportunity to repair and fix
some of the historic colonial
activities of the United States
as it relates to native peoples.
I thought John Dossett
earlier did a really great job
highlighting a variety
of different statutes
and initiatives.
And if you were to
go back through,
you could do a law review
article about each one of them,
about the degree to which
those statutes-- like
the Violence Against
Women Act, for example--
that are designed to repair
colonial intrusions, the depo--
the deprivation of jurisdiction
of tribal governments
over non-Indians, repairing the
degree to which native women
primarily are victimized
within their own communities
by non-Indian men.
That this was about
repairing and fixing
some of the problems that exist
with the native communities,
maybe most if not all.
But it's being done at the level
of the United States government
where you're thinking, we can't
solve the problem by ourselves
on the ground, we have to
go to Washington because we
need to fix those
laws that are in place
in order to repair this
problem, fix this problem.
So that's why I think that
when you talk about maybe
reorienting the agenda
of the United States,
it's really a matter-- and I
think Richard Guest brought
this out in his
presentation-- it's
about the trajectory of how
federal policy has changed.
It was only 50 years ago
that the formal Indian Policy
of the United States
was called termination.
We're going to terminate
indigenous people
as separate people.
And it really started with
the Citizenship Act of 1924.
And I should tell you
now I'm definitely--
along with most of the
members of my nation--
opposed to the
idea that we should
be voting in American elections
because citizenship was not
given to us as some
notion of liberating
our political existence.
It was a tool of
assimilation and oppression
to make sure that
we were absorbed
into the American
polity at the expense
of our tribal sovereignty.
And it boils down to the
fact that a nation does not
enter into treaties
with its own people.
And I heard it from
folks that if you vote,
if you participate at that
level in the American political
system, then what
you're really doing
is you're jumping
to the other side
and then there was no one
left to speak for the treaty
Indians.
The reason why I know
that's true to some extent
is that that's what the
adversaries of sovereignty say.
You're all citizens now
and the minute the Congress
did that, your treaty
rights disappeared.
So it's something to be
very concerned about,
and I respect that
different native people
and different tribal governments
make different decisions
about what's best for how to
articulate their view forward.
But it's something at
least in our nations,
we generally don't do.
That doesn't mean
we don't engage.
And diplomats-- you know
it's kind of lobbying.
John pointed out, lobbying.
It's, you know, diplomacy.
Right?
We're-- we're on diplomatic
missions when we go
to Washington, and we go to
Albany to deal with other
diplomatic representatives,
like members of Congress
and senators.
And there's a way
to make progress.
And I think it's
really great that there
is progress being
made on a number
of these different issues.
And that's kind of
back to the experiment,
what I have really been
trying to do the last three
years since I left
office, is to be involved
with some major battles,
to protect and defend
the sovereignty and the
freedom of our nations.
John had mentioned in his
presentation which I thought--
I wanted to just take a
little bit more time-- is
a recent battle that
related to protecting
native people and the benefits
that tribal governments provide
to native people from the IRS.
The Tribal Government General
Welfare Exclusion Act.
And this was something
that I was lucky enough
to work on behalf of
one of my clients.
But if you can believe
it, right, for 10 years
the IRS was auditing tribes,
auditing individual Indians,
forcing tribal governments
to give 1099s to elders
for their hip replacements.
Pay tax, Granny!
That's what the IRS
was saying and that
was what was happening.
And no-- no one talks
about their audits.
So this was kind of
going on for 10 years
that there was this--
oh you got audited too?
You're getting audited?
We got audited twice.
And when you started
piecing it together,
people-- native
leaders were realizing
this was a systematic problem.
That kind office
over at the IRS that
was trying to help us with
our payroll tax records
was actually in the
business of auditing us.
So the first mobilization
occurred with respect
to the Affordable Care
Act and tribal health
care benefits were
immunized and that
was a big-- that was a big win.
And then the whole
process was really
taken to a complete
level that we
need to fix this problem
for all benefits.
As tribal governments
have the responsibility
to serve native people,
have the resources to serve
native people,
tribal governments
should not be subject
to tax, income tax,
nor should their
people for the benefits
that are being provided.
And so there was a
two pronged process
going on in 2013 and in 2014.
One was engaging
directly with IRS
to try to push them to
develop their own policies
and the other to
pursue legislation,
to go to the Congress.
And there's a certain
internal debate and discussion
about building coalitions,
about finding a way
to sort through the what's the
right policy approach to take.
That's a democratic process.
There are tribes all over the
country, tribal organizations
that are constantly working on
a number of different issues.
But we were able to get focus.
We all agree we should stop and
find a way to protect ourselves
from the IRS.
And we found members of
Congress totally willing
to help us do that
and it was a big win.
We ultimately got a bill
through the Congress.
No hearings.
No real votes.
Voice vote, both houses.
And I think that's
where you see the power.
I mean it wasn't quite
Seneca's on the highway,
but to me it was.
It was.
We got a bill
through the Congress.
This will protect native people
forever by having it in the tax
code that the IRS cannot tax the
benefits that our governments
provide.
And so it makes a
difference, exciting
that when you can do
things that will make
a difference for Indian
people in Washington,
you want to hang onto
it and embrace it
because it can and will
happen if you're not the best.
A couple thoughts on just
the downside of the system.
The level of hostility
to tribal sovereignty
is something that you
may be familiar with,
but depending upon
where you are in America
it starts with gross ignorance
about what tribal sovereignty
is and what treaties are.
It blends in a little bit
to the casino confusion.
Well you all have casinos
now and have all the money,
so why do you need to have
federal appropriation's
dollars?
And that's just such
a wrongheaded, skewed,
misinformed perspective because
most places in Indian country
remained unbelievably
impoverished
and have not had the benefit
of tremendous gaming wealth.
But that influences
and it's something
that really is a part of the
way in which a lot of Americans
still think and their officials
still think about what's
going on in Indian country.
And I think frankly, some
folks are fairly informed.
They're very educated
about tribal sovereignty.
They just hate it.
They just think it's
wrong that there should
be such a thing as separate
sovereign tribal nations
within the United States.
And there are groups and
there are members of Congress
who in their own way do what
they can to undermine that
and to oppose us when it
comes to the preservation
of our nations.
I don't want to talk
oftentimes publicly, too much
about what's going on in
the American elections,
but we are very much at the
cusp of an unbelievable wave
of American nationalism
that we haven't
seen since World War II which
ushered in the termination era.
And if you look at the
historical parallels,
I think as native people we
have to be very concerned
about what's happening in the
American political election
this time around.
Because among other
things, is it really
going to be the case
that we're going
to have this same level of
respect, of our treaty rights,
of our lands, of
our governments?
I'd be very worried
about that, and I
think that we should be aware
of the historical parallels
that the last time
something like this
happened it was
during the termin-- it
began the termination era.
So these are somewhat general
thoughts about where to engage.
So the question might be
to get-- to sort of start
to close here is-- all right.
So it's been 30 years since
I got out of law schoo--
or since I started law school
and I'm still working on it
in terms of this experiment
about where best to engage.
So I would say as a general
matter, clearly both.
I mean you need to have
people on the ground,
in the community, within the
tribal government working hard
to make things better
and I'm a little worried
about that for my own
tribe and maybe all tribes.
Because one of the
things about American--
being colonized
by Americans-- is
that the American
way of life is rooted
in a certain
aspiration of happiness
and freedom, personal freedom.
It's not really an
ethos that's rooted in,
you should sacrifice
and suffer to be
a-- to be an American citizen.
It's just the opposite.
And I think a lot of folks,
it's easy to be drawn into that.
TV sends us these
message, the media.
And to say, well, I want to
go work with my tribal nation
which is not always fun
and which is hard to do,
and it doesn't have 16 different
kinds of pizza nearby--
is not a really
fun life sometimes.
But if you don't do it,
especially those of you
who are natives,
those of you who
have a role-- even
if you're not native,
there's roles to
play-- if there's
nobody on the ground
of strength and means
and fortitude and virtue,
then our governments will
wither away and
they'll die off, and we
will be left to the forces that
would seek our destruction.
So who knows whether I'll
ever get back involved.
I really don't think
it'll ever happen.
I feel like I've
paid in my dues,
and I know my family
feels the same way.
But I think it's an
important point to focus on.
And I think with respect to
the American political system,
I mean it's made-- it's changed.
It's so different, even gaming.
The last time, you
know, the government
really even studied the
question, say of our economies,
was during the Reagan
administration.
And so there's a lot to be done
yet about improving economy,
about finding ways to
help tribal governments
deal with what's happening
within our nations.
Focus.
If you're going to be
involved in either direction,
you have to focus on
what your task is.
You can easily be
distracted and drawn
into all kinds of
different agendas.
There's a lot of folks who talk.
Not a lot of people
who get things done.
And if you want to be
involved, you really
need to want to get things done.
Stay disciplined.
Stay focused.
And sometimes that's
hard and I tend
to think that-- I really think
that my legal training has
helped me a lot over the years,
in terms of helping focus
and really laser in
on particular problems
in a way that might
help get things done.
Work hard.
And this was
mentioned earlier too,
working hard, about finding
a way to focus on the task.
There are people out
there who shame me
in terms of their work ethic.
It's unbelievable.
Leaders especially,
who've been in place
in some cases for
decades, dealing
with all of these challenges.
I don't know how they do it.
But thank goodness that
they do because there's
so many challenges
that this effort.
And that's not always the case.
I was just reading the other day
that the current generation is
having a hard time holding on
to their investment bank jobs
on Wall Street because
it's kind of boring
and it's really hard
work and gosh, you know,
that $150,000 or $200,000
a year just isn't that
much to hang on to those jobs.
And that's a real message.
I was reading that,
somewhat shocked.
So doing things where it's
not always the most lucrative,
or it's somewhat of a
challenge, is really important.
But if you work hard
at it, you can really
achieve tremendous goals.
So as I conclude, I
want to just maybe bring
this all together and just
offer a suggestion on what
might be the most
important thing that we
could be working on.
And I think it's controversial
for some, but at the moment
it's where I think
it's important
and that's improving
tribal economies.
That our economies
have been devastated.
And I start from the assumption
that all native people
were rich, that we were wealthy,
that we lived within the land.
We lived within our resources.
We lived within our people.
We fought and had
conflict with each other,
but we had what we needed
and we had the notion
that this was a good life.
And most of that has been taken
away, confiscated, stolen.
Whether it's the IRS taking
our money because they think
we're citizens of
the United States,
whether it's development
companies looking to gain title
and resources to
tribal lands-- you
know-- whether it's
folks up in Alaska
who had the entire country, but
ended up with only 10% of it
and just a small
fraction of the wealth.
These economies
have been destroyed.
And when you talk about
how best to help people,
it invariably comes back to
whether they have the money
to do anything about it,
whether it's fully implementing
the powers under the
Violence Against Women
Act in your tribal
courts, whether it's
helping your elders or dealing
with children in distress--
if you don't have dollars, if
the tribal government doesn't
have dollars to be
able to find a doctor,
to find a care provider,
to find some way,
then tribal
governments can't help.
And you can't wait around.
So some of the folks that
I work with have largely
been saying if the federal
government can't give us
the dollars that
we're entitled to-- I
love Karen's notion that we
were already sort of prepaid,
so where's our money?
You know?
If you can't pay up,
give us our freedom back.
Get your regulators
out of our pocket.
Get your taxman
Give us the control that
we need over our lands,
and then we'll find a
way to create businesses
and create jobs and do what we
can to help our tribal people
have a better life.
And so at the moment,
that's where I'm at,
in terms of helping to find
ways for native people,
native governments,
entrepreneurs, create jobs,
find revenue, change federal
laws that inhibit growth.
John's argument or presentation
on the Indian trader
statutes-- a fairly
unsexy statute
in the annals of federal
statutes-- you know,
the one that said all
the non-Indians had
to have a license before
they could do business
with the Indians-- can
actually be a great tool
to protect us from
ill-gotten gains going
to the state and
local governments,
and we can preserve those
dollars for ourselves.
It's not sexy sometimes,
but it's really important
I think that we find a way
to help tribal governments
and native people restore
economy so that then they
can make the choices that
they need with the dollars
that they generate to repair
some of the mistakes that have
been made, some of the agendas
that have been inflicted on us,
and ultimately to
pursue the goal
and lifeblood of the
people that they represent.
So I want to thank you for
your time, [INAUDIBLE].
And I want to be able to share
with you any further thoughts
on this now or later.
But I thank you again for
the opportunity to be here.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
-Hello.
Thank you very much.
-You're welcome.
-You spoke a lot about having
great economic viability
for these different tribes.
How do you think the tribes
using their resources
to generate those profits
needed to pay for the programs
they need can factor
into that goal?
-How do they need to do it?
Well, I don't know of any
tribal nation that has
a tax base of any significance.
There are a few tribes
that collect taxes,
but the basic business
model in the American state
and federal and
local governments
is that you tax income, you tax
businesses, you tax property
and that doesn't exist
within any country
as a general matter.
So tribes run
businesses-- casinos
being the most significant
and prominent--
but could be a grocery store,
could be a gas station.
-In terms of natural
resources like wood or timber,
what do you think that
would factor into it?
-Well, I think that there's
an increasing recognition
that renewables are better.
There are many that
don't have renewables
and much of their
economy sometimes
is based upon hard rock
mining and other business
activity that exists really
everywhere in the world.
My nation for many,
many years probably
was kept afloat by gravel
mining in our territory.
And eventually we've
had some recent debates
over moratorium on that
because we just don't think
we should be doing it anymore.
So sovereignty sometimes
manifests itself in behaviors
that you may not
like, but a tribe
has authority with respect
to its own territory
to do what it sees
best for itself
and that may include
that kind of development.
-Thank you.
-Sure.
-Hi.
I'm Anne Flaherty.
I teach political science
at Merrimack College,
and I also grew up
in upstate New York
and watched the 1992
conflict unfold.
So I was glad that
you mentioned it.
But in recent years,
the state of New York
has gone back to
attempting to assert
its right to tax cigarette
sales on reservations.
And it's not just New York.
It's other states, too.
So my question was, how
can states and tribes
forge a more
cooperative relationship
when there is ongoing
conflicts like that?
-Well, it depends on
finding good-hearted folks,
good-minded folks within
the state government.
And again, in an effort to
solve problems-- sometimes
it's just ignorance.
And in the way dollars flow,
rarely in a tribal nation
does the dollar
flow more than once.
It comes in, and
then it's immediately
leaving the territory,
grocery store, car dealership,
or whatever.
And when you realize that if
we did that in my nation--
we did an economic study
and we demonstrated that
through direct employment,
through contractors,
and through other
economic stimulus--
we were contributing
over a billion dollars
to the regional economy, which
is an awful lot of non-Indians
who became taxpayers.
A non-Indian employee at the
casino who has enough money
to buy a house is
paying property taxes,
they're paying sales
tax on their purchases,
they're paying tax on their
income because they have a job.
And I think for a
lot of folks that I
saw from the time I was
first in tribal office
in the early '90s--
just a dozen years
later when we had the
casinos-- educating these folks
and making them
realize, it's a win-win.
Every time a tribal nation has
land that's not subject to tax
and turns it into something
productive, it helps everybody.
And I think that's the
path forward, is hopefully
finding good-minded,
good-hearted folks in state
government who can appreciate
that it's a win-win.
-Thank you.
-Sure.
-Hi.
My name's Leland
Pacheco Morrill.
I'm Navajo and Santo
Domingo pueblo.
And I kind of want to address
the Cobell Agreement which
also is-- kind of supersedes
the land buyback program,
which is part of the
Dawes Act, which is what?
120 years ago?
150 years ago?
And then also, the Nebraska
versus Parker where the Omaha
Tribe did actually win.
But that was actually
based on alcohol tax,
and then it was
redrawing the lines
of the actual property of a
reservation system in Nebraska.
Now each one-- both of those
aspects of it-- one of them
is to try to reconnect
fractionated lands.
And the only reason why
I even know about this
is because the Navajo tribe
actually came to Los Angeles,
to an urban setting,
to actually talk
to natives in Los Angeles
regarding the land buyback
program because so
many of them owned land
on a reservation
they don't live in.
And so, but-- but the
land buyback program
is-- was introduced kind of
to give back an economy, back
to fractionated land.
But also then, you have
the Nevad-- Nebraska Parker
case that was trying
to take away land.
Do have any comments
on those at all?
-I feel like this
is kind of Jeopardy
where I'm getting asked, please
form your answer in a question.
[LAUGHING]
-You have touched upon a
whole array of after affects
of, again, the
colonization agenda.
All these fractionated
reservations
and all these divided
land interests,
and it's really pretty
straightforward.
You can't really
do much with land
that you don't have
jurisdiction over.
So the current
administration really
should get a lot of applause
for channeling resources
into reacquiring, allowing
tribes to reacquire
these lands within
their territory,
so they can self-govern
and they can
find a find a way to--
but it's a long process.
I mean, in some cases you have
hundreds of ostensible owners
of parcels of land.
And on two occasions,
the Supreme Court
has invalidated
efforts by the Congress
to allow the lands to
be consolidated back
into the power of the tribe.
So it's a very hard thing.
But it also raises a bigger
question which might be,
where-- what's the source
of economic opportunity
for tribal nations?
I was literally at a
conference a couple of days ago
having a conversation
with a tribal leader
and I said, "Well, you
realize that the income earned
by a tribal government
anywhere in America,
including off territory,
is immune from income tax?"
Didn't know that.
So what that means is that
there are potential business
opportunities for a tribal
nation off territory
for which at minimum,
there's no income tax
for the benefit of the tribe.
That's a pretty
significant advantage
in relation to other businesses.
So I think your
question is a great one.
It's an unbelievably
complicated issue,
but there are
efforts as you since
heard about how to solve it.
OK.
Yeah?
-Hi.
My name is Karina Kesserwan.
I'm a lawyer in Quebec, Canada.
And you talk about treaties
and interpretation of treaties
and jurisdiction over treaties.
And I'd like to know
if in your opinion
a treaty can be later appealed
by one of the parties.
-Well I think, I mean the answer
is yes because it's a treaty.
It's an agreement.
And it isn't necessarily that we
like Lone Wolf versus Hitchcock
which says that you can
abrogate an Indian treaty.
But my own people
seriously debated that
during our '92 war.
Should we actually go back
to pre-treaty conditions?
Warfare.
You know, it was a debate,
and we didn't do it.
And there-- but
there was actually,
what would happen if we did?
And so I don't know
if there'll ever
be circumstances in the
future where that matters,
but it's an agreement.
And I suppose if you really
take agreements seriously,
you have to respect the
sovereignty of both governments
to that treaty.
-Rob.
Thank you so much.
That was fantastic.
Thank you.
That was great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]